[Música]
son las 8 y 28 de la noche en Bogotá
quito y Lima continuamos en directo
América edición nocturna Les agradecemos
su sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
medios de comunicación alemanes aseguran
que Berlín habría accedido autorizar los
envíos de sus tanques leopardos a
Ucrania y que el anuncio oficial se
realizaría este miércoles esto cuando se
cumple en 11 meses de guerra y el
presidente ucraniano vuelo de lensky
anunció que Está realizando cambios de
altos mandos tras acusaciones de
presunta corrupción Tenemos reporte
desde Berlín
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte
volvió a pedir perdón por las alrededor
de 60 vidas perdidas en medio de las
protestas y enfrentamientos que golpean
al país y llamó una vez más al diálogo y
a convocar una tregua nacional la
mandataria dijo que la violencia que se
vive es responsabilidad de radicales
el ex vicepresidente de Estados Unidos
Mike pence se unió a la lista de
políticos que han guardado documentos
clasificados en su residencias los
abogados del ex funcionario informaron
que se encontró un pequeño paquete de
archivos en su casa de Indiana ampliamos
la información desde la capital
estadounidense
y damos inicio en Alemania que parece
haber tomado una decisión el canciller
de ese país olafón se habría autorizado
el envío de los tanques leopardos a
Ucrania el envío sería directamente por
parte de Alemania y desde terceros
países bajo autorización de Berlín una
decisión que tiene lugar después de
semanas de presión por parte de Ucrania
y de la otan al gobierno germano para
que decidiera su envío para reforzar las
tropas ucranianas ante la respuesta
alemana a Estados Unidos también estudia
la posibilidad de enviar sus tanques
Abraham entre tanto Rusia advirtió del
posible aumento de tensiones
Alemania enviará 14 tanques leopardos
dos a Ucrania según medios locales
Es la primera vez que Berlín autoriza el
envío de estos vehículos militares que
por su naturaleza armamentística
diseñados para alcanzar objetivos de
hasta 5 kilómetros están destinados a
operaciones ofensivas y no defensivas lo
que representa un cambio de estrategia
significativo de los países europeos en
la Guerra de Ucrania que ya cumple 11
meses
esta decisión Del canciller Olaf shows
era esperada por el presidente ucraniano
bolodimir zelemski desde finales del año
pasado cuando las tropas de kiev
comenzaron una exitosa contraofensiva en
el este y sur del país contra el
ejército Ruso y las milicias
separatistas de la región del Don Bass
Polonia que había autorizado a comienzos
de enero el envío de los tanques
leopardo Ucrania dependía el visto bueno
de su vecina Alemania para concretar la
transferencia debido a que estos tanques
son de fabricación alemana por lo que
más temprano en una conferencia de
prensa El Primer Ministro polaco
aumentaba la presión sobre shorts
Alemania es el país más grande y debe
hacer una enorme contribución a esta
coalición conjunta de países que ayudan
a Ucrania hemos presentado esta
solicitud y esperamos una pronta
respuesta por supuesto ya estamos
entrenando a soldados ucranianos en
Polonia otros países también lo están
haciendo y Seguiremos haciéndolo
ahora con la autorización de Alemania
terceros países también podrán
transferir tanques leopardo a Ucrania en
Europa 10 países poseen este armamento
de los cuales Polonia y República Checa
ya dieron luz verde Rusia ha advertido
anteriormente que el envío de tanques de
guerra Ucrania por parte de occidente
generaría consecuencias catastróficas
los tanques leopard son considerados
claves para las maniobras terrestres y
en la actualidad son el mejor tanque
europeo
continuamos en Perú donde la presidenta
Dina boluarte pidió una tregua nacional
para el diálogo en medio de un estallido
social que deja alrededor de 60 muertos
la mandataria reiteró su apoyo a las
fuerzas del orden acusadas de reprimir
violentamente a los manifestantes y
cargó contra la agenda política como lo
llamó de las protestas criminalizando a
los organizadores del estallido Social
Marina sardinha tiene los detalles
disculpas el respaldo a las fuerzas del
orden y su negativa renunciar son 50
personas que han fallecido en mitad de
estos actos de protesta y de violencia
y me duele cuando se van a cumplir seis
semanas de protestas antigubernamentales
en Perú la presidenta Dina boluarte hizo
un llamado a una tregua nacional para
restablecer el diálogo con los miles de
manifestantes pero atribuyó al caos y la
violencia de las últimas semanas a
grupos radicales reiterando su apoyo a
las actuaciones policiales durante las
protestas Pese a que organismos
humanitarios y manifestantes denuncian
una brutal represión eso es una acción
violento generado por un grupo
de personas
radicales que tienen como agenda agenda
política y económica Este martes los
manifestantes volvieron a salir
pacíficamente a las calles para exigir
entre otros pedidos la renuncia de
boluarte a quien acusan de estar detrás
de las más de 60 muertes durante el
estallido estábamos viniendo por toda
esta Avenida de manera pacífica y de
repente esta policía mira todo diseñada
todo organizada para poder bloquearnos
creen que somos vándalos asesinos
terroristas No señores aquí nosotros
marchamos de manera pacífica por el
momento boluarte apuntó que no dejará el
cargo hasta que no se celebre en
elecciones y pese a su llamado a una
tregua los organizadores de las marchas
reclaman su renuncia como condición para
las mesas de diálogo no puede ser
posible que siga una dictadura donde no
hay democracia no hay paz Ellos dicen
diálogo pero diálogo para qué Para para
el agua para el desagüe para carreteras
no el pueblo existe acá una salida
política y la salida Es que la señora
el miércoles la mandataria tendrá una
reunión con la comisión permanente de la
oea señalando que contará la verdad
vamos a Estados Unidos porque los
abogados del ex vicepresidente Mike
pence informaron en las autoridades que
el exfuncionario ayudó documentos
clasificados en su residencia de Indiana
según la defensa de pence los archivos
estaban en su casa por error Por lo que
ni el mismo ex funcionario sabía que se
encontraban allí para analizar esta
información conectamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en
Washington DC Cristóbal qué detalles hay
de este nuevo hallazgo y Cuáles pueden
ser las consecuencias tanto para pens
como para el partido republicano
se conoce por ejemplo que estas cajas
primero estaban en la casa de
Virginia del ex presidente después
llegaron a la casa en Indiana y
Greg Jacob que es representante del ex
vicepresidente dice que
estos cajas llegaron allá de forma
inadvertida las cajas además seguían
selladas con cinta de la casa blanca y
que cuando se encontraron fueron
directamente enviadas a una caja fuerte
para después ser entregadas a las
autoridades las autoridades precisamente
ya tienen pues acceso y control de esta
información confidencial archivos
nacionales ya recibió esta información
el departamento de Justicia también sabe
de esta información lo que no se conoce
Son detalles sobre Qué exactamente
decían estos documentos y qué grado de
confidencialidad tenían consecuencias
claras para el vicepresidente de cara
obviamente a su carrera para la
presidencia él abiertamente ya lo ha
dicho
precandidato presidencial por el partido
republicano y esto lo mete en este manto
de dudas sobre Por qué se llevó esta
información confidencial y que había ahí
si la compartido con otras personas que
pueda poner en riesgo la seguridad de
Estados Unidos
y cuáles son las reacciones de perdón
Cristóbal Cuáles son las reacciones
desde Washington sobre este tema
precisamente el expresidente Donald
Trump que también está siendo
investigado por llevarse documentos
confidenciales a su mansión en mara lago
en su red social dijo que por favor
dejaran tranquilo a Mike pence a su
vicepresidente que él ha sido inocente y
fue inocente durante todo su
administración de cualquier crimen que
se le acusa que lo dejen tranquilo y
pues varios congresistas ya han salido
también a defender de alguna manera a
Mike pence diciendo que no creen que
haya habido intención mala
tratado el vicepresidente de haberse
llevado documentos o secretos de estado
sin embargo pues lo dice el
vicepresidente que está siendo
investigado y lo que se lo que se espera
es que también el congreso que en este
momento la cámara de representantes es
republicano y ya empezó una
investigación también para Joe biden
Pues precisamente ese congreso sea
cuestionado de por qué no entonces
empezar también una investigación Alex
vicepresidente pens por haberse llevado
o tener estos documentos confidenciales
En todo caso muchos cuestionamientos acá
en Washington sobre esta Nueva Ola de
líderes llevándose documentos
confidenciales a sus lugares privados
Cristóbal usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación estaremos muy pendientes de
lo que puede ocurrir en Estados Unidos
con este tema y continuamos justamente
en ese país porque el presidente Joe
biden volvió a pedir una prohibición de
armas de asalto esto tras los recientes
tiroteos que golpearon a Estados Unidos
en la madrugada del martes tres personas
murieron en el estado de Washington Y
solo el lunes nueve personas perdieron
la vida en California y Iowa esto luego
de la balacera del sábado que dejó al
menos 11 fallecidos también en
California
Así que la conclusión aquí es que
tenemos mucho de qué hablar ayer mi
amiga Diane Einstein re introdujo su
prohibición de armas de asalto en el
senado les pido a todos que envíen eso a
mi escritorio lo más rápido que puedan
la enviada de Naciones Unidas para Haití
declaró ante el Consejo de Seguridad que
la violencia relacionada con las bandas
criminales alcanzó niveles no vistos en
décadas de acuerdo con el reporte solo
en 2022 hubo
1.359 secuestros Y al igual que los
asesinatos han aumentado por cuatro años
consecutivos alcanzando los 2.183 el
organismo internacional reiteró su
llamado para que sea enviado al país
caribeño una fuerza internacional que
sirva para garantizar seguridad y de
tranquilidad para retomar el rumbo
político social y económico
en otros temas el reloj del fin del
mundo indica que estamos más cerca que
nunca de un cataclismo los expertos del
boletín de los científicos atómicos nos
acercaron al final diez segundos por
entre otras cosas La amenaza nuclear
vinculada a la guerra en Ucrania Gabriel
colchón nos cuenta más
Eres
faltan 90 segundos para la medianoche en
el reloj del fin del mundo Y eso
significa que la humanidad está más
cerca que nunca de un cataclismo global
es lo que el bulletting de los
científicos atómicos un grupo de
expertos encargado de este proyecto y
que incluye a 10 premios Nobel anunció
Este martes el reloj simbólico es
ajustado cada año desde 1947 para dar
cuenta de los riesgos globales de una
catástrofe la medianoche es la hora
fatídica que se espera que nunca se
alcance la guerra en Ucrania y la
amenaza nuclear llevo los científicos
adelantar el reloj de 10 segundos En
comparación con el año pasado
no se puede descartar la posibilidad del
uso nuclear los accidentes los errores y
los errores de cálculo podrían provocar
una escalada no intencionada y Putin
podría escalar deliberadamente si se
enfrentara a la perspectiva de la
derrota Si las fuerzas rusas fueran
expulsadas del territorio ucraniano
Putin no ha dado indicios de estar
dispuesto a aceptar la derrota además de
la guerra en Ucrania los científicos
tuvieron en cuenta la crisis climática
la pandemia del covid-19 pero también la
desinformación entre otros sin embargo
los expertos no pierden Esperanza
creo que entonces existe la posibilidad
de que pulsemos un botón de reinicio y
reabramos una serie de iniciativas
diplomáticas para abordar los retos de
las armas nucleares el cambio climático
y las demás amenazas a las que nos
enfrentamos hoy en día
el reloj fue creado durante la Guerra
Fría para advertir de los riesgos
nucleares que podrían llevar a una
destrucción global lo más lejos al fin
del mundo crítico fue en 1991 al final
de esta guerra estaba entonces a 17
minutos de la medianoche
América Latina estará presente en la
entrega de los premios Oscar 2023 la
película argentina 1985 resultó nominada
en la categoría a mejor película
internacional la industria
cinematográfica Argentina llega a los
premios Oscar nuevamente y lo hace con
una cinta de Santiago mitre que retrata
la lucha del fiscal Julio César
estrasera para conseguir la condena de
las juntas militares que gobernaron el
país suramericano durante la última
dictadura militar en la próxima edición
del programa la entrevista de France 24
que se estrena esta noche a las 21:45
hora de Bogotá dialogamos con Alejandra
flesher actriz argentina y una de las
protagonistas les presentamos un
fragmento de esta entrevista
oportunidad son muchas emociones esta
película nos nos viene dando muchas
emociones desde su estreno en el
festival de Venecia que se veía al
público por primera vez Yo tuve la
fortuna de estar en ese lugar y lo que
vivimos esa noche fue algo inolvidable
Porque además vimos por primera vez la
película con público Entonces ahora
Bueno uno ya sabe que la gente le
encanta lo que la película es sucede lo
que sucede pero esa primera vez fue como
muy alucinante y todo el recorrido de la
película internacional fue muy
alucinante muy loco a veces pensar que
un hecho de si bien es una ficción pero
es sobre nuestra historia sobre un
momento muy importante de nuestra
historia
no te imaginas que en otros lugares
pueda tener ese esa resonancia creo que
la película
La tiene muy fuerte primero porque
dialoga muy fuerte con el presente un
eso violento digo que rompe pactos
democráticos que quiere golpes de estado
o discursos de odio y hoy la película
nos viene como a recordar no a muchas
cosas a poner en valor muchísimas
cuestiones segundo que las personas
jóvenes las propias de nuestro país las
chicas los pibas los pibes de 15 años
les pregunten a sus padres y vos qué
dónde estabas en el cuando se fueron los
coches a las juntas tenías diez años
sabías lo que estaba pasando esa
conversación que se dio en Argentina no
solo a nivel internacional sino dentro
de nuestro propio país la película fue
un acontecimiento social y eso es es
mucho más de lo que la película poder
aspirar
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en Francia 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que ya llega Andrés espinal con
toda la información de nuestros
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]